on the outside this Chapel looks like a
normal Cathedral but on the inside the
gilded shrine to the Catholic faith
welcome to the capilla del Rosario the
capilla del Rosario or rosary Chapel the
sound inside the Church of Santo Domingo
in Puebla Mexico it was built in the
17th century between 1650 and 1690 when
was the first Chapel of Mexico dedicated
to Our Lady of the Rosary or the Virgin
Mary the chapel was it's goldleaf and
ornate details as we consider the eighth
wonder of the world
in 1979 pope john paul ii called the
Rosary Chapel a relic area of America a
shining example of Mexican Baroque
architecture chapel has ornate
sculptures oil paintings statues and
moldings covered in 23-karat gold leaf
the centerpiece of the sanctuary in an
altar dedicated to the Virgin Mary even
was enough gold to fill secured Peng
state the church regularly holds mass
and other services for worshippers
anyone religious or not can appreciate
the golden glow of the capilla del
Rosario
you